so much i want to talk to you about uh
let's talk about the movie of course
first you play a bad guy in this movie
like
a bad guy is that fun for you it was
a lot of fun it was a lot of fun yeah it
was just one of those you know i even
have a cane
whenever you get to have a cane you know
you know it's going to be a good day
yeah where do you begin to kind of
get into the mindset of a guy like this
because he's he's a little twisted
yes i mean you know when i read the
script
this was a dream character for me
you know i i i saw right away i was like
wow this
is a special i mean to me it's it's a
dream role
so it's scary because you don't want to
mess that up um
and um and i also came into this project
pretty late so i didn't have a lot of
time at all
okay um so and and also i'm doing like a
philly accent which i hadn't done before
so yeah there was a lot of like
questions i was a little
terrified i wasn't sure you know because
i'd rather
not do something great than do something
great poorly
you know yeah yeah definitely okay so
what made this role such a
did you just say your fiance yes is it
nice saying that now
it is i think that's the first time i've
said it to another person
wow and how does it feel uh it feels
really good
oh that's awesome okay we'll
i'll get back to that but
you know getting into you know will i be
able to
nail this and then i had a conversation
with the director you know i felt good
about that and
and i realized also that the the dialect
is
pretty similar to some dialects that i
have done before i've done other sort of
east coast
uh dialects and um so
and then and then but the big thing was
that it clicked in that i actually
grew up with this guy um
so i i found the person in my upbringing
that i could just completely
play how would you describe this guy
a very charming uh
um violent
uh sociopath um
that you know absolutely was a bully but
could be
incredibly persuasive and just made
people around
him do exactly what he wanted them to do
and uh and then really knew how to put
the fear in them if
if someone deviated from his plan and um
and yeah so so when that clicked into me
you know because i remember
so clearly because i looked up to this
guy
but i was also terrified by him and uh
and you know i was like infatuated with
with this guy and also so drawn
to how people you know
related to him and and that he just got
people to do what he wanted and they
were afraid of him and
uh but you know but also looked up to
him
and um you know
that version of him i've actually run
into him uh
later in life and uh not much to look up
to you know
it's uh yeah yeah sad so i mean
he he was a successful criminal for a
while and then he just
went off the deep end when you're in
folks and stuff
as it often happens but but yeah so so
when when i found that guy that i could
actually
use him and then i understood how to
sort of
my my physicality and and the the
posture and walk and how i physically
related to people around me i was
looking
always you know looking for an angle for
weakness
how to you know capitalize on each
social situation and
interaction so when all those things
kind of clicked in for me then um
yeah then i was uh i was i was good to
go and and it it
i really found flow in this character
much
much sooner than i usually do i mean on
the first day on the first
take i just started improvising and
playing with it and
because i sort of i knew the character i
just knew it
from from the get-go i just had this guy
and
and then you know i was on set with the
guy like matthias schoenartz
who you know is a an incredible actor
uh i mean i think he's one of the the
great actors of our generation
and um and he's also the kind of
personality that doesn't get intimidated
if someone else has flow and and is
doing good
you know that can happen sometimes
especially with these sort of
performative actors they're the kind of
actors that come in and
give a performance but they don't really
play with you
so you're not creating together they
they come and they
give their performance and then they
walk off to their trailer
yeah you know so
matthias he's like uh you know we play
together and we
and you create we create this world
together and it becomes this
it really is like when you when you were
a kid and you were at the playground
i don't know if you remember but you
remember that feeling when you were at
the playground and
you just found someone that just also
believed in the game
you know and all of a sudden it became
so fun like this guy's good at playing
you know and then
and you could just play for hours with
that person
that's kind of the same feeling um and
and
so with me matias neither of us are sort
of
these like method actors that uh you
know that
demand that everyone else behave in a
certain way um
but we were definitely sort of in
character the whole time and were
playing with it the whole time so
it felt pretty seamless when the camera
was
rolling and when it wasn't um
yeah i was i was i just started dating
uh my
uh my now fiance and and i went back to
stockholm for
uh a few days i had a little break
and we'd only like hung out a little bit
and she was like very unsettled
because she i was she was like you're so
different now
and i'm like am i she's like you're like
a different person
because i had a different walk and a way
of looking and you know
it really is like sunk its teeth into me
really quickly it was pretty
wow and wait this is when you guys first
started hanging out
yeah yeah it was it was like yeah the
yeah it was a couple years ago
oh that's amazing so maybe she kind of
like that darker side of you
that's amazing um and i wanted to ask
you but last time
that we spoke to you is for the secrets
we keep and you said that that was one
of the most intense filming experiences
that you'd ever done so
would you say this experience was a
little less intense than that
yeah it wasn't intense because i didn't
have you know numerous
uh torturing me in a basement for five
weeks
it's not like a super light movie but um
but yeah
it wasn't that it wasn't that kind of
intensity this was more yeah this was
much more playful
and um yeah it was
more okay well you know i gotta ask
about your fiance you brought her up i
saw i can see her in the background
um congratulations on your engagement
thank you how has this past week been
for you you know you put out the
pictures on social media everyone was so
excited for you how do you how do you
feel
yeah i feel great i feel great you know
happy to
announce it to the world you know yeah
oh those are your dogs uh is my puppy
oh you're [ __ ] oh no
hi oh so cute how old
she's one year oh very nice um
you know when you think about you and
kelly walking down the aisle together i
mean
what kind of goes through your mind uh
that has not gone through my mind yet
just had to get through the proposal
yeah yeah yeah
i will take one thing at a time you know
yeah
the pictures are so beautiful were you
guys like up on a mountain or a hill
yeah we did we i took her on uh um
it was a uh a sunrise hike
was she surprised she was shocked
really she was shocked
okay were you nervous yeah but i knew
that if she said no
i had you know the short way down it was
really quick i just take a quick jump
and uh just end the pain right there
that's good okay so if you're gonna go
up high you're gonna open that you need
to have your escape route set up
the escape route uh was assembled
that's amazing um you got so much
support from so many people it was
really fun reading all the comments from
everybody i'm sure
you did that too um and we also got to
see that olivia munn gave
her you didn't read them no oh my god so
we
read them that's amazing okay well you
just got so much support from everyone
including olivia munn was it nice to
kind of get her support
now that i'm telling you the first time
sure that's that's good yeah she sent me
a text so i thought that was really
sweet
ah okay and last question to wrap things
up we just interviewed your suicide
squad
co-star idris alba he said he has the
best suit
in the film do you agree with that or do
you think yours is a bit better
um he definitely has a better suit than
me that's for damn sure
um yeah he's got a pretty
the suit is pretty good i gotta say it's
pretty good
it's pretty good i mean
john cena's is the most ridiculous um
idris might have the best so yeah that
might be true actually
you